welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today is an ask me anything
episode or AMA this is part of our
premium subscriber Channel our premium
subscriber channel was started in order
to provide support for this standard
huberman Lab podcast which comes out
every Monday and is available at zero
cost to everybody on all standard feeds
YouTube Apple Spotify and elsewhere we
also started the premium channel as a
way to generate support for exciting
research being done at Stanford and
elsewhere research on human beings that
leads to important discoveries that
assist mental health physical health and
performance I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar the hubman lab
premium channel generates for research
studies the tiny Foundation has agreed
to match that amount so now we are able
to double the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental health
physical health and human performance if
you'd like to subscribe to the hubman
laab podcast premium channel please go
to huberman lab.com
premium it is $10 a month to subscribe
or you can pay $100 all at once to get
an entire 12mon subscription for a year
we also have a lifetime subscription
model that is a one-time payment and
again you can find that option at hubman
lab.com premium for those of you that
are already subscribers to the premium
channel please go to hubman lab.com
Premium and download the premium
subscription feed and for those of you
that are not hubman Lab podcast premium
subscribers you can still hear the first
20 minutes of today's episode and
determine whether or not becoming a
premium subscriber is for you so without
further Ado let's get to answering your
questions the first question is about
colds and flu and the question
specifically is why is it that we get
more colds and flu in the winter months
is it the temperature outside is it the
fact that people are spending more time
indoors or is it a myth that we get more
colds and flu in the winter months well
the first thing is that the research
very clearly shows that in winter months
there's a greater prevalence of colds
and flu now of course the words in the
winter months means many things for
instance in most areas of the world
unless you live directly near the
equator in the winter months means that
days are going to be shorter and nights
are longer than in the summer months in
general that's true it's of course
especially true if you live very far
from the equator so imagine somebody
living up in trsa Norway which is very
close to the North Pole in Winter days
are very very short in truma and
conversely in the summer months days are
very very long in tromsa Norway now
truma Norway represents an extreme of
daylength variation according to time of
year the closer you get to the Equator
the less variation there is in day
length and therefore night length across
the year however in most locations on
Earth days will be significantly shorter
by about an hour or two at least for
certain parts of the year and in general
shorter days correlate with colder
temperatures that's what's really
important to know which is that shorter
days generally correlate with colder
temperatures regardless of where you
live on the planet Earth okay so in the
winter months as we're calling it
involves at least two things shorter
days which means what it means less
sunlight and either more artificial
light or more Darkness depending on how
much artificial light you rely on it
also means as we mentioned colder
temperatures colder temperatures of
course doesn't necessarily mean that you
are exposed to those colder temperatures
because what's the third thing shorter
days and colder temperatures outside
mean that people are spending more time
indoors so what the research clearly
shows is that one of the reasons not the
only but one of the reasons for the
greater prevalence of colds and flu in
the short days a AKA winter months of
the year is that people are spending
more time indoors and therefore at
closer proximity which raises a whole
bunch of really interesting questions
that have been explored in the
peer-reviewed research about proximity
cold and flu transmission there have
been studies for instance where people
come into the laboratory who are
suffering from cold and flu and are
sneezing having them sneeze at different
proximity to other people obviously
people are doing this under consent
they're agreeing to participate in these
particular experiments and there does
seem to be a very nice relationship
between physical distance between you
the uninfected person and the sneezing
coughing nose wiping eye wiping we'll
get into why I mention all of those
things in a moment person that is
suffering from the flu in other words
the closer you are to somebody who's
sneezing or coughing the higher
probability that you will contract that
cold or flu Okay so we've already
established two things first of all
physical proximity is a key variable in
terms of transmission of cold and flu
and at some level that's sort of a duh I
mean if you think about it if you're in
the Next Room or down the hallway from
or across the street from somebody with
a colder flu you don't expect to
contract that colder flu from them
whereas if you're in the same vehicle
with them or you're sitting next to them
on an airplane or you are on the same
bus or in the same classroom as them and
they are sneezing and coughing well then
the probability that you would get that
colder flu from them is increased that's
just obvious but the studies that have
explored the relationship between
physical proximity and transmission of
Cold and Flu have actually analyzed
things down to the range of well if
you're standing one foot apart or you're
standing 3 feet apart or six feet apart
what's the probability that you will
contract that colder flu and it follows
a very direct relationship where the
closer the proximity the more likely
that you're going to contract the colder
flu from that person and of course
anything like exchange of skin contact
or exchange of saliva because obviously
in cases of romantic relationships where
people will kiss or in familial
relationships or friendships where
people hug any kind of contact also
further increases the transmission of
Cold and Flu not just from stuff emitted
from the nasal passages and from the
mouth when people sneeze and cough but
also when people wipe their eyes even
when people wipe their skin because
oftentimes they have cold or flu virus
on their skin it doesn't always survive
terribly long on the skin but if they
wipe their face or wipe their nose or
are using tissues and then don't wash
their hands thoroughly afterwards indeed
they can transmit cold and flu simply
through handshake okay so for all you
hypochondriacs out there I'm arming you
with a lot of useful knowledge that will
justify staying away from people who
perhaps have cold and flu now this
particular point about proximity and
people being indoors more during the
winter months and that's why there's
more cold and flu transmission raises a
whole bunch of interesting questions and
in fact protocols that I plan to cover
in a huban Lab podcast episode solely
devoted to colds and flu and how to
avoid getting colds and flu but one
brief mention or Telegraph of what I
plan to cover in that episode is that if
people are telling you that they are
sneezing and coughing due to a colder
flu but that they are quote unquote not
contagious either because they are early
in the colder flu or late in the colder
flu and they have these theories or
claims that oh you know I'm no longer
contagious uh keep in mind that anytime
someone is sneezing or coughing they are
in fact contagious so I'll get back to
that in that full length episode about
colds and flu but I felt it was too
important not to mention right now that
people's theories about when they are
quote unquote contagious or not
contagious are rarely substantiated by
the actual data the actual data point to
the fact that when people are sneezing
and coughing if it's due to a cold or
flu they are still contagious Okay so
we've established that cold outside
means people tend to be indoors more
which increases physical proximity which
is one of the reasons why there's more
cold and flu transmission one of the
other reasons why being in indoors more
tends to increase cold and flu
transmission is that in the cold months
of winter when people are indoors they
tend to be not under air conditioning
not at neutral temperatures but rather
they tend to be in heated rooms and
depending on the type of heating that's
used but in general due to all forms of
heating the heated air tends to be drier
air now this is a little bit
counterintuitive because if you ever go
outside on a really cold winter day
you'll realize that the cold weather
Outdoors is extremely dry you can almost
quote unquote feel the dryness of the
air and if you can't quote unquote feel
the dryness of the air or imagine what
that's like just imagine this think of
yourself Outdoors on a very cold winter
day taking a brisk walk then think about
yourself taking that same brisk walk on
a very humid summer day humidity is of
course the concentration of water in the
ambient environment the air whereas the
dryness is the LA lack of humidity and
just that little simple gunan or thought
experiment will remind you just how dry
the cold air is out of doors during the
winter months whereas indoors we're
heating that air and indeed the heating
of that air does have the property of
drying the nasal and oral passages but
especially the nasal passages so another
key reason why there's more transmission
of colds INF flu in the winter months is
because people are spending more time
indoors and often times the way those
environments are being heated is drying
out the nasal passages and the nasal
passages represent a primary sight of
defense for viral infections like colds
and flu but also bacterial infections
and fungal infections for that matter
now I've talked before on this podcast
about the importance of using nasal
breathing under any conditions where you
don't have to breathe through your mouth
so if you are not eating if you're not
speaking or if you're not exercising
hard which by the way oftentimes
requires that you breathe through your
mouth there's nothing wrong with
breathing through your mouth if you're
exercising hard and you need to breathe
through your mouth in order to bring in
enough oxygen there are conditions under
which that's entirely appropriate you
can learn more about that in the podcast
episode I did all about breathing and
breath work but for the most part it's
best to be a nasal breather except under
the conditions I just mentioned why well
the nasal passages contain a number of
physical barriers including the hairs
within your nose I know that hairs in
the nose uh especially if they are super
numerous are not considered
aesthetically nice uh people will trim
them Etc but those hairs in your nose
actually serve as a barrier toward
infection this is well
established the lining of the nose the
mucosal lining of the nose contains a
lot of things first of all it acts as
its own physical barrier and physical
trap for incoming viruses fungal
infections and bacterial infections they
literally get trapped in the nasal
passages and therefore can't enter
deeper into your physiology and right
now is not the time to go into the whole
anatomy and phys Theology of the nasal
passages but keep in mind if you saw the
episode that I did with gnome soble or
you listen to the episode that I did on
all faction both of those episodes
highlight the fact that your brain sits
not far behind your nasal passages
there's a a bony barrier there called
the cior plat and there's some other
things as well but it's not far from
your nostrils to your brain and it is
not far from your nostrils to the rest
of your respiratory pathway of course
and so the hairs of your nostrils the
mucus itself and the microbiome the
trillions of little microbacteria that
thrive in the mucosal lining of your
nasal passages actually serve to protect
against many of the incoming infections
this is why it's so important to keep
the mucosal lining of your nasal
passages thriving and intact how do you
do that well one of the best ways to do
that is to make sure that the air that
you're breathing is sufficiently
humidified so while there are many
different claims out there about how to
avoid colds and flu as long as we're
having a discussion about why there are
more colds and flu in the winter months
because indeed there are it's worth
mentioning that if you suffer from colds
and flu and you're going to spend a lot
of time in an particular indoor
environment you might be wise to find a
air humidifier something that brings
more moisture into the air that you're
breathing especially at night while
you're sleeping now that's not going to
prevent the person in your environment
who happens to have a colder flu and is
sneezing actively from transmitting that
colder flu but it will keep your nasal
passages and the rest of your
respiratory Pathways as healthy as they
can be and as resistant as they can be
to any colds or flu that you might be
fighting off and this is another key
point which is regardless of whether or
not it's the winter months or the other
months of the year all day long you're
combating different types of infections
different types of viral fungal and
bacterial infections are bombarding your
system and your immune system counters
that both through physical and through
neurochemical and hormonal and pure
immune mechanisms okay there's a whole
discussion of this in the episode I did
on the immune system we'll do more on
this but keeping the air that you
breathe especially at night sufficiently
humidified is one great way to try and
offset colds and flu that you might be
combating because you brought that cold
or flu home from work and your immune
system needs to Ward it off okay if you
are having a hard time grasping how it
is that you could bring home a cold or
flu and then Ward it off like do you
have it do you not have it is it sitting
there trying to get into your system or
do you have it a little bit well this is
some of the gray area around cold and
flu and viral transmission generally I
mean we don't know for instance if you
got a mild sniffle as opposed to a
really bad colder flu whether or not it
would have been a really bad colder flu
had you slept less had you not
humidified your air better Etc probably
it would be if you've ever not slept
well for a little bit and you're sick
you experienced just how much worse that
sickness feels the symptoms of that
sickness go from very mild to moderate
or from mild to moderate to very severe
when you are or sleep
deprived that said it's also clear that
some strains of the colder flu can be
more mild than other strains of the
colder flu so this can be pretty nuanced
and we'll go deeper into this in the
episode that I do on cold and flu and
how to avoid cold and flu but nasal
breathing whenever possible day and
nighttime is extremely important for
encouraging the overall health and
resistance of your respiratory Pathways
to incoming cold and flu and other types
of viruses similarly humidifying the air
that you breathe especially at night but
perhaps also during the day in your
office environment or home environment
can also be very beneficial for warding
off colds and flu and if you'd like to
read more about the nasal versus mouth
breathing components of colds or flu
I'll just mention one paper now and
again I'll go into this in more depth in
the future episode on colds and flu but
I want to mention that this is a biral
effect meaning people who deliberately
breathe through their nose tend to get
fewer colds and flu also people who tend
to breathe through their mouth more more
tend to get more colds and flu now you
might think that's the same thing or
just two sides of the same coin but
actually it's not there's what we call a
double dissociation whereby if people
are mouth breathers they are far more
susceptible to colds and flu and other
types of respiratory illnesses I'll put
a link to one particular paper that I
like a lot in the show note captions
entitled Association of oral breathing
with dental malocclusions and General
Health in children this paper explores a
lot of different things about nasal
versus mouth breathing all of which by
the way point to the fact that nasal
breathing whenever possible is better
for us healthwise aesthetically Dental
healthwise than is mouth breathing but
one of the key components here and this
is why I bring it up in the context of
this discussion is quote oral breathing
is related to a significantly higher
prevalence of allergies and a
significantly more likely getting sick
and taking medication for being sick
okay so lots in this study Lots in
related studies but nonetheless being a
nasal breather humidifying your air
paying attention to whether or not
you're indoors with people who are
coughing and sneezing because it's cold
outside all of those things are going to
be relevant perhaps keeping a little bit
of distance maybe a lot of distance from
those people or encouraging them to wash
their hands after they wipe their nose
maybe even sending them into a little
bit of uh not necessarily isolation
although that might be necessary but
keeping them at a distance right I don't
think it's uh too much to ask somebody
who's sick to not get you sick uh
personally I think that's the polite
thing to try and do and there's actually
uh not many things Rudder than someone
who knows that they're sick showing up
to something because they didn't want to
miss that particular event and getting
everybody else sick frankly that's my
opinion I think uh that opinion is
shared with many of you out there as
well now as I mentioned earlier when
it's cold outside the air tends to be
drier not always I mean you could live
in an environment that's very cold and
very rainy obviously very rainy is very
humid it's maximum humidity if you think
about it but if you are going to spend
time out ofd doors in cold days of
winter which by the way is a really good
thing for other reasons I'll get into
those reasons in a moment because they
relate directly to why there's such a
prevalence of colds and flu because in
general people are not doing what I'm
about to tell you to do but there are
two things to keep in mind if you're
going to be out of doors first of all
all the things about proximity still
hold right there have been studies of
people who have colds and flu sneezing
in indoor environments for versus
outdoor environments and how much
transmission there is again it boils
down to proximity yes you can get a cold
or flu from somebody sneezing Out of
Doors next to you just as well as you
can if they sneeze next to you indoors
there's a slightly higher probability
that you'll get it from them if they're
sneezing at that same distance but
you're indoors as opposed to Outdoors
obviously sneezers coughers sneeze and
cough in the other direction cover your
mouth and nose if you don't have a
tissue or something we are told and I
subscribe to the idea that sneezing into
your elbow or coughing into your elbow
is probably the next best thing to not
covering up at all um as opposed to into
your hand which then you touch other
things and yourself anyway without
getting into the mechanics of sneezing
and coughing too deeply if you're going
to be outside in the cold winter months
and you'd like to avoid getting colds
and flu when you run when you exercise
when you walk when you're in
conversation try to nasal breathe unless
you have to mouth breathe and if you can
sense your nasal passages or your mouth
drying out because of that hard
breathing and by the way exercise during
the winter months is still important so
I'm not discouraging people from
exercising Outdoors during the winter
months as long as you can do it safely
but if you feel those air passages
drying out just be aware that when you
take those dried out air passages
indoors and you're around other people
that might have colds and flu you are
going to be more susceptible so that's
cause for taking a hot shower perhaps if
you have access to a steam room or
humidifier and rehydrating those those
nasal and oral passages now if you're
outside and running and you're breathing
hard and your nasal passages are drying
out does that mean that you're more
susceptible to colds and flu that are
just out in that environment if no one
else is around chances are no however
what we were all told when we were kids
which is if you go outside and you get a
chill it's a good idea when you come
back inside to take a hot shower a hot
bath or if you have access to it a sauna
to heat back up that's also true why
well ites does seem that there's a
relationship between core body
temperature and susceptibility to cold
and flu and this is something I'm going
to go deeply into in the episode on
colds and flues keep in mind that fevers
that are the response to exposure to a
colder flu or being full-blown sick with
a cold and flu are an attempt of your
immune system to heat up that virus and
destroy it keep that in mind if you're
considering taking any kind of
medication to lower your fever of course
know that highly elevated body
temperatures AK fever can be very
dangerous dous to the brain and body
yeah there's a fairly limited upper
range of temperatures that we can go
into before we start damaging ourselves
but also keep in mind that fever is an
adaptation designed to destroy viruses
okay so if you blunt the fever you are
actually letting a colder virus to
proliferate more readily than it would
if you allowed a slight fever to combat
that okay so there's a whole discussion
to be had there because obviously you
don't want people cooking their brains
due to elevated fever and not treating
that fever but you also don't want to
reduce your core body temperature too
much which raises the question of things
like cold plunges should you be taking
cold showers and doing cold plunges in
the winter months when it's already cold
and you're susceptible to colds and
maybe you're coming down with a cold
should you do that ah well that Segways
into the next question that I'm going to
answer for this AMA which relates
directly to cold exposure and so-called
cyclic hyperventilation breathing
sometimes associated with so-called Wim
Hoff breathing but other forms of
deliberate breathing as well and how
specific forms terms of deliberate
breathing and how deliberate cold
exposure can indeed be used to offset or
even prevent entirely infection due to
bacterial or viruses but if you're
already coming down with a bacterial or
viral infection why cyclic
hyperventilation breathing or why
deliberate cold exposure may actually be
the worst thing if you are already
Contracting or if contracted if you are
Contracting or have already contracted a
cold or virus so we'll answer answer
that question next in the meantime just
know that yes indeed in the winter
months you are more susceptible to colds
and flu because there's more of them
going around we talked about some of the
reasons why they're going around and
some of the things you can do to protect
yourself against those colds and flu
there are a bunch of other things that
you can do that are very valuable that
we'll explore in the full length episode
on colds and flu and how to avoid
getting them and I'm hoping you all stay
clear of colds and flu these winter
months and now you have some tools to
try and reduce the duration and severity
of those colds and flu should you get
one
thank you for joining for the beginning
of this ask me anything episode to hear
the full episode and to hear future
episodes of these askme anything
sessions plus to receive transcripts of
them and transcripts of the hubman Lab
podcast standard Channel and premium
tools not released anywhere else please
go to huberman lab.com
premium just to remind you why we
launched the hubman laab podcast premium
channel it's really twofold first of all
it's to raise support for the standard
hubman Lab podcast Channel which of
course will still be continued to be
released every Monday in full length we
are not going to change the format or
anything about the standard hubman Lab
podcast and to fund research in
particular research done on human beings
so not animal models but on human beings
which I think we all agree is the
species that we are most interested in
and we are going to specifically fund
research that is aimed toward developing
further protocols for mental health
physical health and performance and
those protocols will be distributed
through all channels not just the
premium Channel but through all channels
hman Lab podcast and other media
channels so the idea here is to give you
information to your burning questions in
depth and allow you the opportunity to
support the kind of research that
provides those kinds of answers in the
first place now an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel is that
the tiny Foundation has generously
offered to do a dollar for- dooll match
on all funds raised for research through
the premium channel so this is a
terrific way that they're going to
amplify whatever funds come in through
the premium channel to further support
research for Science and science related
tools for mental health physical health
and performance if you'd like to sign up
for the human lab premium channel again
there's a cost of $10 per month or you
can pay $100 Upfront for the entire year
that will give you access to all the
amas you can ask questions and get
answers to your questions and you'll of
course get answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well there will
also be some premium content such as
transcripts of the amas and various
transcripts and Protocols of hubman Lab
podcast episodes not found elsewhere
and again you'll be supporting research
for mental health physical health and
performance you can sign up for the
premium channel by going to hubman
lab.com premium again that's hubman
lab.com
premium and as always thank you for your
interest in
[Music]
science